I remember one thing my mom said she
said don't let anyone ever tell you what
to wear I don't think that I was always
considered a
beautiful but it didn't matter because
What mattered was what I thought of
myself and also I got to let my racket
do the talking
hi this is Venus Williams and this is my
glamor unfiltered definitely for years I
wore a bunch of eyeliner and now I've
moved on to lashes as opposed to winery
but it was definitely like this eyeliner
I figured it was like my suit when I
walked on the court and called it the
eyeliner Club sorry and I seem to be the
only ones in it but we were in it to win
it I think that was that's probably like
my favorite part of is like wearing
makeup at you know in a sporting job
that's really fun when you walk out
knowing you look great you feel great
you're ready to play
for us it was always important to know
where you are who you are because if you
don't know who you are in your history
you'll have no idea what you need to do
to be ready for the world my parents
definitely pushed history on us to know
the history of the world history of our
of African Americans I think especially
in challenges that we face
in the world when you're a different or
a minority and honestly each and every
lesson was
important but I think the most important
one was that for us not to see color
that didn't matter for my parents it's
like you don't you don't need to see
color people might see your color but
that's not how you see the world so I
think it's important for each and every
parent to teach their child that yeah at
the time I didn't know that I was
different and now I realize how much
very different I was but difference is
what makes the world beautiful and I
think people really can see that now in
terms of what Serene and I have
accomplished in the sport and what that
has meant and how it's elevated even the
world in that sense you know people
necessarily didn't know my culture so
when people saw that you're you're
wearing braids and Beads I may have
thought that it was unique but people
from my own culture would have realized
oh wow this is something that that young
young girls do so I feel like I'm still
educating people about my culture you
know one at a time like you know this is
this is normal like people of African
descent or with ethnic hair we often do
wear braids we often do wear beads and
those sorts of things have very deep
meanings actually from the origins what
matters is that you don't lose yourself
as an individual
and that you know who you are
individually and you also know what
works for you and that you don't have to
be everyone I think that's something
that a lot of young women are facing
right now is this pressure to look
standardized and I've never gone for
that I always wanted to look like me I
always felt less comfortable if I was
pushed into something that was everyone
else and I think that influence
definitely comes from my family and my
parents that pushed individuality
confidence in yourself and playing
sports I believe gives you that because
you sit there and you fail and you
succeed and you see what it takes to
actually be great and so then hopefully
at that point your standard of greatness
and who you are as an individual really
becomes something that you that you
relish and grab onto I don't think that
I was always considered a
beautiful but it didn't matter because
What mattered was what I thought of
myself and also I got to let my racket
do the talking
I think that the standard of beauty
right now is more inclusive so that's
wonderful but at the same time there's
tons of pressure you know I think the
standard of beauty 20 30 years ago was
like be as thin as possible you know and
now the center of beauty is kind of
shifted more to like be as curvy as
possible now there's pressure to you
augment yourself to fit into the
standard somehow and that's not
realistic so either standard wasn't
realistic but I'm happy that it's more
inclusive at this point and like I said
it's about knowing yourself you just got
to know you be comfortable with you
except you and if that means also
augmenting that's fine too as long as
you accept yourself
I've always worked in rest periods and
my parents taught us that too so they
never wanted us to because on tour you
could play every week literally so you
would also go crazy and break your body
that balance is important and burnout is
real and you have to find your balance
for me at the end of the day just like I
have my two hours of quiet nobody's
there no one's talking I guess when you
have kids you can still have that you
put in a bid or something and then you
might have a husband or significant
other
I don't know how you quiet them but
I don't I don't know how any of this
works outside of a single life but I've
got my little routines at work for me
I've had a single life for a long time
and I think it's really easy to get
stuck in a single life and sometimes at
least for me harder to get out of a
single life so that's probably something
I'm working on now I guess for other
people like they were running to a
relationship which has never been my
thing per se so we're all different
this is how I work and function and I'm
okay with it and can't hold on to either
relationship or a single that you have
to be able to move at the time and even
if you don't want to or aren't ready you
just gotta go with it I'm not ready to
grow up
I gotta grow up
yeah for in my household money was not
emphasized I mean obviously you want to
be successful but it wasn't like you
don't chase dollars so I grew up with
that mentality if not of money not being
a God in that in this sense in this
world it is a God
people are chasing it
you know and stabbing themselves over
with many pains and and other people and
so if if we all could kind of see money
a little bit different probably would
have a lot less issues in the world
so that helps you to actually make
decisions that are good for you healthy
for you and have less pressure to so I
didn't feel the pressure at a young age
to have to sign a contract because of
money
and that that was is very freeing when I
was growing up I just wanted to play
tennis and go win tournaments and then
when I got there it was not equal and
you're like whole depresses what's going
on so being a part of achieving equal
prize money for women at the major
tennis tournaments was fantastic and now
of course it's my dream that women will
not have to face that anywhere no young
girl will have to come in and realize
that her male counterpart is being paid
more and hopefully these gaps will
continue to close but in order to close
those guys we have to do work and we
also have to create awareness because
most people don't wake up in the morning
and look in the mirror and say gosh you
know so-and-so is getting paid less and
so and so so it's so important to change
these mentalities at every single level
whether it's the employee or management
leadership Etc on and on and on yeah
Serena and I are very codependent
uh we do the same thing that the other
one does I mean it's just happened again
last week
it just goes on and on as the endless
cycle when you're 80 years old and like
I want to do it too
you know but it's it's more of a
motivation and when I see her doing
great it's my success but it's also
motivating for me and lets me know I
also can do that and that's how you have
to look at other people's success it's
something that builds you up something
that motivates you I love seeing people
do great I love seeing people do well I
don't like to see anyone fail I like to
see my opponents lose against me but
other than that I like to ride that
energy that other people bring with
success I want to be a part of that and
that's the attitude that I like to have
and Serena has taught me so much and
there's so much you can learn just from
from being around greatness and that's
what she is the greatest ever oh my gosh
brownies are so important in life if you
don't have them anything's gonna happen
I remember one thing my mom said she
said don't let anyone ever tell you what
to wear
I remember taking that to heart she's
like I used to wear my short skirts and
I still wear short skirts
and she says how are you gonna wear
short skirts and I'm like until infinity
and beyond those those kinds of lessons
are so important and I think we're
learning that so much today right with
the Mental Health crisis that's around
the world that you do have to set
healthy boundaries and you have to do
that work on yourself to set boundaries
so that way you aren't afraid
and once you let go of that fear then
the whole world's open to you faith is
extremely important to me first of all
without faith then what do you have it
can be scary
uh second is that for me it gives me
guidelines to follow and it helps you
not to be alone so you're not having to
make all these decisions alone you're
not having to Wonder Maybe what's right
and what's wrong it allows you to
have that safety blanket and actually
keeps you safe we all make mistakes I
make lots of them but I'm always trying
to align back to Center definitely being
healthy especially with what I do as an
athlete if I'm not healthy I can't do it
so every day that I'm healthy these days
I'm very
very excited about it and like excited
to wake up and go play health keeps me
connected to gratitude because without
it you have nothing
um definitely having
um
spiritual aspect to your life makes you
gracious and it's something you have to
practice you don't practice it it's
going to be something that's in the
background too there's lots of Articles
lots of people lots of blogs lots of
twitters there's a lot so you have to
kind of Shield yourself from that so
that way you can really meditate on what
you think and also being proactive about
your thinking and you can actually train
your mind to think the way you want to
if you put in the time and also another
one is just not caring I just don't care
I just don't care what anyone thinks and
I don't have time you're not going to
live my life you're not going to breathe
for me my heart's not going to beat for
you and Deuces it takes a long time to
accept it especially as an athlete
I create my realities so to have a
reality pushed on you is something that
is not really acceptable so I think it
takes time to like okay yeah this is a
thing you know and of course it was
important for me to fight for my best
health yeah definitely I thought that I
just didn't have to protect my skin
because I already had natural SPF and it
wasn't until you know my mid-30s that I
realized gosh I'm wrong now when I play
even in the Florida heat when it's 90
degrees and I think I might die I'm in
long sleeves and pants
it's rough and I'm in sunscreen is you
know
as much as I can through the profuse
sweating that I do in the
re-applications
but it's so important your Skin's your
biggest organ you have got to take care
of it by what you put in it I don't
remember which one it was there was so
many together but I wore like this Dolce
Gabbana dress and it had like a silver
bodice and I just I just felt like me I
was so happy I was happy for a week I
was so happy because I was like this is
me this is absolutely me I was on cloud
nine setting your intentions is
extremely important and you have to put
work behind it too so Mind Body Action
it all works together that's so
important I suppose it's called
manifesting today back in my you know in
the 80s it was called having a plan and
having some goals so you know same thing
I guess manifesting sounds a lot
smoother I love a cleft bag
fun my mom or scene did not allow
microaggressions in the home
and she would not allow us to have
people
be that passive aggressive around so I
never had to deal with that in my life
and I have a very short fuse for it some
people like drama and that's their
choice
I think a lot of people have drama in
their lives that's what they like they
like it so I stay out of it and my with
my friends I give them maybe one advice
and then
you know people know you don't have to
say things more than once you have to
beg anyone it's not in a bag in business
I'm a real chill girl so
your choice
oh my legacy
I think that
um it's not something I think about
I don't know do people wake up and think
I'm in the right now I have a tournament
coming up trying to play
what am I going to achieve in this
moment I've always been so
forward-looking and I think a Legacy
isn't as important as just enjoying your
life